[Music]
a struggling retail chain is at the
center of what some people are calling a
david and goliath struggle
between big and small investors gamestop
used to be hugely popular with video
gamers but it's been hit hard by changes
in business
that set the stage for a wall street
showdown that's starting to affect the
broader market
vladimir duche has been following this
story vlad so many people are talking
about this what exactly is going on
anthony good morning you sound like one
of my old clients when i was a vp in
investment management so let me tell you
what's going on
in less than a year the company's stock
has jumped from less than three dollars
a share
to almost 350 dollars how and why that
happened has caused rumbles on wall
street
as small investors apparently joined
forces to beat the big traders at their
own game
to main street it's the world's largest
video game retailer
but on wall street gamestop is the
latest battleground between the
financial elite
and small investors shares of the
company have soared nearly 800 percent
over the past week driven by anonymous
post on the reddit forum
wall street bets stephanie metta is
editor-in-chief at
fast company they're kind of sticking it
to the big institutional investors the
hedge funds
by basically forcing the big guys to
lose money
because they had been shorting or
betting against gamestop
here's what happened all last year
gamestop was struggling its stock
selling at less than 20 dollars a share
big wall street investors saw an
opportunity they
started shorting the stock betting the
price would drop
if it did they would make money but if
it rose
they'd take a loss that action angered
small investors
who use the reddit form to encourage
others to buy
driving up the stock price dramatically
and creating
massive losses for those big-time wall
street investors
on wednesday gamestop stock closed at
almost
350 dollars a share it is a company
that sells products that are widely
available
online from other sources it is
competing against
companies like amazon you can see why
companies bet against it
some small investors said they made tens
of thousands of dollars
one said it would help pay for medical
treatment but
one major hedge fund citron capital says
it took a 100 percent loss in covering
most of its stake in gamestop
what do you make of what's going on with
gamestop you know i'm fascinated by it
jamie rogozinski created the wall street
bets reddit forum back in 2012.
he says small investors like being the
masters of their own wall street destiny
there is something to be said about the
fact that pretty much anybody can do it
too and watching them do it collectively
is certainly a
certainly a show but where there is
reward there is also risk
at the end of the day the best way to
invest in the stock market is
to either work with a financial advisor
work with a retirement portfolio manager
and if you do see a stock that you're
interested in investing in
do the research and buy essentially on
the fundamentals
and it's not just gamestop reddit
investors appear to already be moving on
to their next targets movie theater
chain amc
saw its stock surge more than 300
percent just on wednesday
after the hashtag save amc began
trending on twitter anthony
thank you so let's bring in cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger jill
good morning
so i got a text from my 20 year old son
in college yesterday saying his
classmates are playing this stock game
and he wants in on it too
what do you tell people like that trying
to get on the market right now
you know as vlad noted in his piece the
experts are saying hey
sure you want to learn about the stock
market that's fine
whatever your son or anyone else is
thinking about investing just pretend
this is money that is essentially
entertainment and education you've got
to be able to lose it
and i think that people are jumping onto
the bandwagon
without understanding the risk so if you
go into it saying
hey i would like to learn more about
this thing called investing
and i'm going to do it by buying shares
that it's
really important that you know you could
lose everything you invest so
no emergency reserve fund no borrowing
to make this happen
and no making this a a be all end-all
or a replacement to your long-term
financial planning
how big a hit jill are the wall street
firms
who were shorting these stocks taking
and what's this doing to the market
well you know it's interesting these
firms these big institutional hedge
funds
they are piling into these bets and
saying hey we don't believe in the
viability of this company
there is nothing inherently wrong with
short selling in fact
short selling has been at the root of
getting
big information out to all investors if
you remember
enron that was a fraudulent company that
was exposed by short selling
so we shouldn't be anti short selling
but
these companies are taking institutional
money rich people's money
they bet against the stock and they lost
it doesn't have any
wider implication in fact if you look at
gamestop stock and it's up hundreds of a
percent
over the last five days the s p 500 is
actually down by a couple of percent
it's one company amid a huge market
is gamestop worth 350 bucks jill and how
does this all
end uh by the way tony
tony does not believe that i heard as we
went into the break uh
i'll tell you the advice i gave to
somebody i know who actually made a
bunch of money in it
and i'm a former trader myself and i
said you know what
you just made a ton of money i would get
out pay your taxes and move on
i think that the reality is for most
people
this is not something you necessarily
want to replicate please if you're doing
it
be very careful how it ends we don't
know hey remember
way back when in 1996 alan greenspan
talked about irrational exuberance
he was right but he was five years early
so just be careful out there good advice
jill schlesinger thanks jill